alors à quoi a ressemblé l'enfance du
fils de jacques mérine d'abord je crois
qu'à part les premières années je crois
que la première véritable rencontre avec
votre père c'est dans le parloir d'une
croix enfin compte grandir normalement
jusqu'à l'âge de trois ans là avec mes
parents à partir de l'âge de trois ans
je suis mis en famille d'accueil parce
que mon père part à l'aventuré se
baladent à semer en famille d'accueil et
mets pas mon père par l aventure au
canada et le temps que mais qui par un
aventurier au canada moi j'ai cru trois
ans je me suis un mytho rien en fait et
de plus rien du tout et appuie revient
en france dans les années 70 cela j'ai 8
ans la mémoire kung fu comment ça
fonctionne et je commence à me rendre
compte que fut comme la moyenne vu que
j'ai pas de parents il ya cette époque
on n'est plus aujourd'hui avec un peu
trop à la mode ou les il ya eu tellement
de couples séparés
à l'époque elle est la plupart des
gamins mois ils avaient tous eu des
parents sont moins connus et c'est là
que je commence à fatiguer à me dire
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va pas quoi
tout doucement le lait et le temps passe
les cours y arrive à la maison des
échanges
ma grand-mère s'enferment dans la salle
de bain avec ma soeur enfin plein de
trucs bizarres que toi de moi bien pour
ça que tu devenu magicien d'ailleurs il
ya eu trop de secret mais parce que je
précède la question qui va nous poser
qu'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
vous vous répondais je suis mal chinoise
et cyril un peu et il y avait trop de
secrets en fait autour de moi et offert
la mesure celle ci découvre par hasard
sur un courrier que reçois ma soeur qui
est signée à la fin au père existe qu'il
est vivant il n'y pas que les vivants
vécu il écrit à ma soeur c'est surtout
moi qui me rend compte qu'ils vivent à
la fois parce qu'à la fin il ya marqué
trop papa qui t'aime moi je dis mon papa
qui t'aime c'est ma soeur donc ne vont
pas passer le mien c'est mathématique et
à partir de là voilà c'est moi qui veut
absolument le connaître rapidement
possible contrairement aux situations
bien différentes de nos trois mois que
le voir peu importe les conditions je le
vois que tu étais la première rencontre
à m au quartier de sécurité de la santé
où je vais et en fin de compte le
deuxième gamins à rentrer dans un
quartier de sécurité en france
alors qu'est ce que ça donne ce soudain
tête à tête entre un père et un fils qui
se connaissent à peine et qu'elle perd
puisque dans l'ordre
sur le coup de quartier de sécurité je
n'ai pas vécu en fait j'étais tellement
pressé d'aller vraiment père que je
voyais plus rien autour de moi j'étais
dans un espèce de nuages
je me souviens qu'à une grande que sur
la sur la soie la gauche tout le monde
parle tout le monde attend ça me
rappelle le barça tout le monde
attendait sur le but tout le monde
attendait sur le côté et hop bruno
marines up directement chez le directeur
on vous accompagne directement voir
votre père et là j'ai suivi dans le papa
je ne sais pas qui il est mais n'est pas
non plus dans la moyenne nuit et le
parloir se passe
ma grand mère va lui parler en premier
et ton fils va arriver et c'est après
ces essais bon tour bon départ j'étais
très fier quelques secondes après
j'étais plutôt comme ça donc il ya les
parloirs c'est juste des petites plaques
comme ça pas très large 1 qui avait
trois vitres mais un petit cadrage au
toit être content j'ai été planqué sur
le petit cadrage j'étais en biais et mon
père j'entends que les bains dans le bon
sens un il engueulait les garder en
étant dépêchez-vous joue à voir mon fils
voilà ça marche je suis devenu blanc là
et plus parlait plus je me cachais 1 et
ils s'assoient dans le parloir effet 1
je croyais que j'avais la visite de mon
fils aujourd'hui et là je me me découvre
gentiment ou totaux témoin voilà ce
qu'est ce qu'il est beau mon fils ça
vaut plusieurs va et ma condition de
seconder mais voyez dans le ton que vous
utilisez pour raconter cette rencontre
vous avez dit quelques instants et une
différence avec ce qu'on a entendu vous
n'avez pas honte de votre père vous ne
le renie et pas vous avez en avait même
l'air d'être fiers même aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est la fierté le moc et
conseiller éric après la récréation moi
je vous dis bien quand on joue et
méchant et ça moi je jouais souvent le
rôle de mesrine j'aurais jamais joué le
rôle d'amy louis michel fourniret est
elle est là la différence mais c'est
vrai quand on jouait le méchant joue et
mesrine salle la chance c'est un bon
argument mais l'intéressé ccss es sétif
hier à l'époque voulait est encore
aujourd'hui
est-ce que fierté le mot qui convient je
sais pas je fait dire fierté oui oui oui
quelque part dans l'absolu mais bien sûr
je suis fier que mon père mon père c'est
pas le sien c'est pas le sien désolé
mais vous comprenez mais vous avez
entendu dans l'horreur pas du tout la
manière pas du tout là là là mais la
mère ne s'est pas grandi avec eux de ce
genre de souffrance en fait moi me la
souffrance était plus l'absence de mon
père plutôt que qui l'inquiétait tout
comme sa présence mois de l'année par
mois moi j'avais là où je l'avais le
plus souvent c'est au parloir c'est là
où vous avez l'occasion le voir le plus
souvent et le plus tranquillement
possible vous celle inverse la prison
c'est totalement la merde moi moi
c'était presque bien au bout d'un moment
d'y aller parce qu'au moins que le
voyais ce qui était plus serré pour moi
ça va être sans censure d'assassinât
parce que comme dirait l'autre je suis
certainement aller seul gamin dans ce
pays où son père s'est fait fi de cette
manière on va revenir
là dessus mais quand vous a présenté oui
oui oui mais quand j'entendais les flics
je suis pas c'est pas mon dieu d'accord
parce que non je voulais savoir c'est
pour ça que vous interrogez sur le mot
fierté parce que quand vous entendez ce
grand flic là qui dit ne nous trompons
pas c'est un tueur très violent sadique
y'a pas voilà c'est pas une idole quoi
évidemment vous êtes votre fils d'un
point de vue très particulier mais voilà
j'ai mon père d'un côté et je suis un
français comme les autres hein mon père
c'est une idole lui c'est aussi mon
idole mairie qui dit que c'est un tueur
mais il a été assassiné par la police
c'est déprimant de langage que vous
attendez je veux qu'on entendrait c'est
un braqueur de banque etc
mais c'est pas un tueur ou la légendaire
travers est il ya deux vieillards de
chasse le garder mais je suis d'accord
mais il faut savoir que les gardiens il
faut savoir que les gardes-chasse au
canada c'est pas les gardes-chasse en
france 1 pincée de vie par daba sélectif
et 17 de vie ces enseignants oui je suis
d'accord mais je voudrais vous expliquer
lé contexte quand même et eux ont été
repérés parce qu'ils étaient en train de
faire de l'entraînement tir dans une
forêt les des gardes-chasse les ont
braqué directement et non mairie les
oraux connus immédiatement et qui a tiré
le premier c'est le complice de mon père
qui a tiré il a été condamné à 2 x 125
ans de prison sont assidus ya eu deux
attendus société nuit ne sont pas et
vous sa production avec les chasser mon
père a rajouté une balle pour chacun
comme si les deux si les deux se faisait
rigoler mais elle est là la peine il a
partagé en deux voilà c'est plus sage
est débile aux amitiés si on peut dire
mais c'est pas lui qui les appuient
voilà non mais je me permets d'insister
alors c'est peut être un peu de mauvais
goût de son fils il admet il à jarry
jeune panda les uns d'accord mais je me
permets d'insister parce que il ya
malgré tout pour les gens qui sont pas
emile louis offrirait à ses deux il ya
une sorte de glorification un peu du
gangster une quinzaine de votre père
elle a fait l'objet de sin d'ailleurs
d'excellence il est joué par vincent
cassel qui à nos meilleurs acteurs des
plus charismatiques donc il ya quand
même pour des gens qui ont beaucoup de
choses sur la conscience et donc on l'a
rappelé un double meurt une forme de
glorification qui parfois moi me dérange
un peu voilà donc pour cela que
j'insiste je comprends mais c'est pas
moi qui ai fait lui un héros un d'abord
c'est lui le programme ont expliqué que
la fascination continue je pense que la
fascination c'est la manière dont il a
été assassiné
ils sont ils auraient été arrêtées au
cours d'un hold up normalement ou
pourquoi pas tué au cours d'un hold up
pour papa sa part et vous
malgré qu'il ait jamais tiré au cordeau
le dr une fois soit les nombreux
nombreux qu'il avait ça sera bien pour
aider l'état la bagnole que voilà à
partir de là qu'on comprend les gens
flic ou pas flics ont été outrés de la
manière dont ça s'est passé parce que
c'est un pur assassinat il n'ya même pas
à calculer
mais bono ne vaut que si l'assassinât
une l'assassinât c'est pas du tout ce
qui a été retenu par la justice ni le
non-lieu qui a retenu la légitime
défense
j'explique juste qui se passe donc tu
repères et pris en filature la filature
sa chef pour de clignancourt
oui yvonne à ce moment là à ce moment là
évidemment la police ouvre le feu dit
qu'elle a fait des sommations et ajoute
que votre père s'apprêtait à prendre une
arme et regarder les photos j'explique
jusqu'au bout et qu'il y avait deux
grenades dégoupillées donc s'ils
voulaient la version de la police c'est
que ça se joue à quelques dixièmes ils
ont fait une sommation innovant pas fait
2 voilà donc l'assassinât je tiens à le
dire parce que nés quand même
responsable juridiquement de ski ceci
dit ce qui se vit sur ce plateau
ce n'est pas ce qui a été retenu par six
mois ce qui m'arrive ça me dérange pas
c'est bien assez sinaï avait pas photo
non mais c'est le deuxième assassinat
qui s'est passé en quarante huit heures
fait par l'état
deux jours avant c'était robert boulin
le ministre du travail le jour après
eric tout héritier parce que vous savez
très bien comment ça se passe dans les
médias lui il n'y a rien de tel qu'une
affaire plus fort pour effacer une autre
affaire le jour que mon père est mort
boulin faisait quatre lignes mon père et
l'a fait là la complétude gouverneur je
n'ai pas du tout je me disais tout à
l'heure que le commissaire broussard que
je connais puisqu'il était président
d'un peu de rugby et me suis dit tu
disais c'est un menteur pourquoi il a
menti sur la faire mais déjà il ment
parce que déjà la version officielle
le voilà le barbu là
il arrive soit disant devant la voiture
mon père le reconnaît il se penche et
caetera et harry faire un geste et tout
déjà ce mec-là est un menteur chronique
depuis le début de l'histoire rappelle
que tout ça n'engage que vous ça
n'engage pas moins non seulement n'y a
pas que moi parce que tout ça c'est
enregistré sur des procédures
chez les juges d'instruction d'huy la
dngc lâché à la presse me gêne jamais
été lâché à la presse
il ya d'autres confidences vous pourrez
prendre votre téléphone et vérifier les
amis les démissions comme ardisson très
intéressante qui avait invité le
commissaire lucien aimé blanc qui a
sorti deux livres qui a confirmé que le
commissaire m e broussard est un menteur
parce qu'il se trouvait à côté de lui
dans la voiture
voilà donc voilà on va pas dire que même
que le commissaire lucien aimé-blanc
patron de le crb est un menteur
le sport surtout que c'est lui qui a
retrouvé mon père n'ont pas bon ça mais
c'est un voyage avait promis il ya deux
choses qui me gêne dans l'histoire
d'abord c'est un coup de la mort de mary
marin la mort de mary est un coup de
communication totale giscard en avait
marre il fallait montrer une bonne fois
pour toutes que mairie ne pouvait plus
narguer la police ne peut plus durer ça
c'est exact ça faisait deux frères
capitale ça veut dire deux mois qu'il
était rues letort il pouvait l'arrêter
ils ont choisi un moment où il été fait
comme un rat s'étaient organisés pour le
tuer non pas pour l'appréhender parce
que l'appréhender il aurait pu le faire
un peu plus tôt ou un peu plus tard il
n'avait aucune chance de s'en tirer et
dans le milieu de la police six ans ils
sont même vantés
c'est la première chose c'est un
assassinat c'est pas parce que mesrine a
tué mais c'est pas parceque merina tuer
des gens ce qu'il a fait que la police à
son tour s'est montré parfaitement
équitable l'un n'empêche pas l'autre et
la deuxième est rythme qui m'étonne
beaucoup chez vous il a tué des gens
mais on n'est pas là non plus pour faire
du moralisme on peut avoir tué des gens
et avoir un panache extraordinaire comme
gangsters et comme ennemi public numéro
un on peut avoir du panache comme tueur
c'est quand on arrive dans une équipe
panache qu'on ne voit oui panache c'est
à dire cas l'apologie de la moi je parle
de ça il y avait dit deux choses dans ce
soir il ya deux choses qui me dérange
c'est qu'à chaque fois comme aujourd'hui
la nuance est morte dès que quelqu'un
n'est pas d'accord
immédiatement avec la version officielle
bing il est dans l'art la carte du
complotisme ça c'est insupportable
la première chose et je vous reprends
sur deux choses mon cher eric parce
qu'on a le droit de ne pas être d'accord
avec vous on a le devoir de nom mais la
première chose c'est que un criminel
peut avoir du panache parce que l'être
humain est complexe et que il ya une
grande différence dans toutes les
affaires qu'on a traité ce soir avec
mais même entre les criminels
il y a des gens qui tuent de manière
tous les meurtres sont condamnables on
le sait et on part sur cette base là
qu'un assassinat et quelque chose d'
abjecte et qu'un meurent plus immoral et
que c'est puni par la loi
il n'empêche que dans la dans le sucré
dans la complexité d'un être humain
il y à certaines personnes qui ont du
panache et d'autre part si on a parlé
autant de merine à une époque où il y
avait jean charles viii look et dont on
a très peu parlé
françois bey zotac par l'insee que mme
erin qu'on le veuille ou non avait
quelque chose en plus sinon il n'y
aurait pas deux épisodes avec vincent
cassel sur lui il n'y aurait pas eu
d'affairé serait plus lent mais parfois
il un danger aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sais où j'en ai marre il
y avait du panache jamais ou bien dont
je réponds rien et ensuite vous avez la
parole je laisse les choses aller vous
plaise ou non mais vraiment on a pris un
peu de temps mais ils semblent avoir
fait preuve de nuance je dis qu à titre
personnel je suis allergique à la
glorification des gangsters je dis pas
que c'est des gens mais ça donne
entièrement à issac je dis ça me dérange
un peu
jeudi 15 ans j'ai encore un enfant j'ai
entendu où j'ai cru percevoir dans ce
que vous avez dit bruno et/ou dit tiens
c'est bien tombé
cet assassinat pour reprendre votre vote
puisque ça fait oublier la sphère boulot
moi je trouve que il ya un petit
mécanisme compagne à magog au nom de
tout le continent
on attend un tour de table s'est
rapidement à la glorification de
quelqu'un qui n'ont à la glorification
de quelqu'un ou la faire c'est vrai que
c'est mal où j'ai manqué de parler de la
guerre ça fait je te prie la plus parlée
bien là mais le moraliste c'est à dire
on ne peut pas se permettre dans les
médias sur une chaîne de télévision
française de faire la glorification de
quelqu'un qui a tué ci dessus une
connaissance dans la nuance l'art de la
nuance
les invités de finissants et
deuxièmement c'est quelqu'un qui a
laissé pour mort quelqu'un qui a été qui
l'a torturé
je suis désolé qu'ils avaient des papes
seulement ont fait le tour du monde un
jour promet bruno racine on ne peut pas
faire ça sur une chaîne de télévision
[Musique]
enfin pour moi c'est pas une question de
mois c'est à dire que on peut considérer
qu effectivement il a commis les actes
illégaux qui sont condamnables pour
autant on n'est pas d'accord avec le
fait qu'une personne soit puni de mort
s'ils n'ont à ce jour pas question à
savoir c'est que les saignements voilà
c'est pour moi ces deux questions
différentes n'estime qu'il n'est plus
dans l'hypothèse où il habitait dans
l'hypothèse d'un d'une activité pendant
du d'une d'une fin de vie qui serait
criminel ce qui me peine qui ne me
dérangerait plus ce qui n'est pas été
jugée tout simplement qu'il n'ait pas
fait face à la justice de ce pays
j'ai une question à vous poser donc plus
personnel donc c'est vrai que vous avez
vraiment parler de votre part avec
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé beaucoup de
nostalgie vous nous avez fait part du
manque que vous avez prouvé et en effet
que deux personnes un pardon et le puits
de quelqu'un un chapeau oui bien sûr non
mais c'est pour ça que je m'étais je
m'identifie à cette relation qu'on peut
avoir un père à l'affection qu'on peut
avoir pour un père plus encore quand il
a disparu de manière brutale donc ma
question je voudrais savoir si vous êtes
capable de lui reconnaître des torts de
manière je suis très très sur la
défensive
j'en suis je me demande dans quelle
mesure nous d'être capables de
reconnaître des torts donc dans ces
activités illégales en tout cas à minima
we will et or est passé compliqué
j'imagine il a une carrière plus de plus
de 20 ans la lande est en train de
parler de d'assassins alors que ce qu'on
veut c'est une carrière le grand 82% à
77 une carrière le grand banditisme
est ce que c'est une carrière c'est une
carrière s'est condamnée par la loi
j'ai seulement voulu chanter bonnie and
clyde faut interdire daniel choisi comme
gainsbourg chante bonnie and clyde tout
le monde trouve ça génial c'est une
glorification de deux assassins je suis
désolé hélas pas un vrai faux mais c'est
aussi une question je voudrais voir mon
père je reviens encore là dessus ce
n'est pas la chasse est un braqueur et
là on a là aussi les jours avec je sais
pas quoi parfum de deux criminels de
chais pas quoi de tueurs il n'a jamais
été compté en france pour aux héros
meurtre 0 meur qu'elle était condamnée à
trente là dessus il était condamné
uniquement pour les les braquages et
surtout pour ces [ __ ] d'évasion parce
que ça ça énerve beaucoup de systèmes
quand un mec est mis au quartier haute
sécurité qu'on a fabriqué spécialement
produit à la santé réussi à se marrer la
même chose qu'il ait fait au canada
quand on le met dans le alcatraz version
version québécoise où c'est encore pire
pire mais le 10 fois pire paix les qhs
version la santé après si elle est
effectivement le meurtre des gardes
forestiers
quand on fabrique des faux faut pas
s'attendre que les mecs quand ils sont
en liberté
agissent comme des agneaux quoi
l'amérique ces questions est en retard
s'il vous plaît jacques mary n'a cherché
à devenir un héros il a construit sa
propre légende que c'est aussi ça qui
l'a fait redescendre 10 et il est
visiblement devenu aéro pour vous aussi
il vous a peut-être aussi beaucoup
manqué est ce que peut-être avec le
recul ne riez pas que vous auriez
peut-être aimé avoir une enfance
peut-être plus normal mais là pour vous
répondre simplement moi moi mon rêve à
moi affiche devant avoir un ce soir
franck magicien je porte à porte des
rêves
j'aimerais bien qu'à la place karl zéro
ça soit en plus ça peut s'arranger
mais ça il faut il rit je veux dire
c'est que moi mon père bien sûr que je
préfèrerais vivant je préfèrerais qui
sort de taule même à 80 verges
même jean avec d'autres enfants de se
retrouver mon père moi moi j'ai pas eu
de père pendant ta mère me distinguer
trois affaires quand un homme samoa mais
on peut dire c'est qu'il est trop à
faire qu'on a traité ce soir je pense
qu'il peut y avoir un parallèle entre
entre les deux premières et on peut
distinguer effectivement le cas de mme
erin va au-devant de l'ériger en exemple